welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Boston Ironman - like its leading man
boldly superhero lands into a broader
cinematic universe with even more
confidence fanservice and Easter eggs
with Marvel forcing director Jon Favreau
to tie in so many MC connections that
the dude was like that's it I'm not
directing the third one only ant-man
didn't puke on him well we've had some
fun in this blue dungeon mark - finding
the new goodies at Iron Man and Hulk
Iron Man - [ __ ] Favreau said we're
getting real with these Easter eggs and
so shall we with another scene-by-scene
breakdown of everything we overlooked in
past reviews let's get started we open
where the first Ironman left off the
press conference when approaching the
sequel Robert Downey jr. said no sooner
has Tony said I am Iron Man that he's
now really wondering what that means and
for Iron Man 2 it means legacy it's
about legacy it's about what we choose
to leave behind part of that legacy is
the history of his father Howard Stark
and the Vanco family Anton Vanko and his
son Ivan Vanko our villain Niki work
Ivan's opening montage it's an ear shot
for shot recreation of Tony's self
forging in the cave in the first film
Ivan Vanko is actually an original
character to the movies an amalgam of
Anton Vanko Crimson Dynamo in the
separate villain whiplash previously
backlash with the villain Zidane
tightening this theme of what comes
after Tony crashed into the world as
Iron Man and now he's failing the post
crash pain of whiplash work had some
freedom with his characterization adding
his bird in gold teeth at his own
expense and insisting on authentic
Russian tattoos yeah that's right we're
doing an eighth down on his torso
there's a Russian schooner with the
words translating to give me a blonde
above all on the boat and I'll sail away
and originally there was a tat of Loki
on his neck but they were moved with the
effects to avoid any confusion among
vanko's many news clippings is an
article about Iron Man stabilizing east
and west relations written by Rob down a
nod to Robert Downey jr. now originally
Tony's intro to this film was going to
show him super drunk on the plane you
may remember the alternate trailer
helmet kiss that was from that the
sequel was originally going to focus a
lot more on the darker themes of Tony's
alcoholism inspired by the demon in a
bottle comics but hear Tony's entrance
is a company once again by ac/dc this
time it's chapter 3 until he introduces
his stark Expo with a clip of his father
now played by John Slattery one of the
first
expos has shown later in Captain America
the First Avenger butthere's Slattery's
performance in city of tomorrow pitch
was all based on Walt Disney and his
Epcot presentations and the credits you
can hear the old expose song make way
for tomorrow today which was an homage
to Disney's Carousel of Progress Tony
fixates on his palladium poisoning when
the antidote is currently being lectured
to him by his father in the form of that
future city layout if Tony could only
listen among the expo attendees are a
ton of cameos Libby Aman Blais reporter
chess Roberts who's a reporter from the
comics she works for whi H the recurring
MCU News Service
Oracle CEO Larry Ellison shows up danly
cameos as Larry King Seth Green appears
briefly in the elevator and kate mara
plays the Summoner to the Senate hearing
now later in the film Tony saves an expo
attendee with an Ironman mask
Tom Hollen and Kevin Feige actually
later retcon this kid as a young Peter
Parker Peter references this Expo
location and homecoming but that kid
actually shows up here in the scene get
him monograph an affectionate little
head pat from tony in real life the kid
was played by Favreau son max now the
Senate hearing is chaired by Senator
Stern Garry Shandling RIT later revealed
in Winter Soldier as a Hydra agent they
debate government oversight here which
is kind of a precursor of this
heightened debate in civil war but I'll
consider Secretary of Defense of last
night's Tony actually was briefly
Secretary of Defense in the comics say
we need Justin Hammer played by Sam
Rockwell Anthony Stark has created the
sword with untold possibilities and yet
he insists it's a shield this shield and
sword metaphor forms the basis of the
organization's shield and as we'll see
in the upcoming phase for sward the
shield off shoe that protects Earth from
extraterrestrial threats actually Nick
Fury may be with sword right now and we
also meet the new Rhodey don cheadle who
makes light of the awkward recasting
from Terrence Howard with a meta joke
here it's me
now really cool detail here hard to spot
long Tony's phone there's an app labeled
Illuminati Marvel's Illuminati was a
kind of superhero shadow Ewan originally
composed of stark Professor X dr.
strange Reed Richards and a more in
black bolt leader adding black panther a
bunch of others thinking in it here was
probably Peggy's way of saying well you
know we got plans and Tony's lab he's
lined up his past suits mark one two
three and four of and look closely at
his holo display they're teasing his
next reveal the mark five a suitcase as
pepper argues about whether Tony needed
these stark Expo the screen behind her
shows Howard's layout of the community
of tomorrow which is of course the
atomic structure of the new element
ironically proving that Tony did need
the expo Lego gets travel documents for
a member of the ten rings terrorist
network the one with Reza and the
Mandarin not that take her but the real
Mandarin to be revealed in the upcoming
shang-chi in the legend of the ten rings
mangoes alias on his passport is Boris
Turgenev whose name also appears on his
pit crew jumpsuit that burns off in the
comics Boris torgan off was the name of
the guy who took over the Crimson Dynamo
mantle from Anton Vanko in Tony's boxing
gym we get a nod to happy Hogan's origin
as a boxer in the comics and we meet
Scarlett Johansson as Natasha Romanoff
Black Widow here using the name and
Natalie rushman taken from her Nancy
rushman alias in the comics and Tony
heads to Monaco where he briefly meets
SpaceX and Tesla CEO Elon Musk and one
of my favorite Institute details the
photo that gets taken a Tony and pepper
here later shows up framed behind Tony's
bar in stark tower in the Avengers in
the race one of the cars is sponsored by
rocks on the Marvel energy conglomerate
which appeared in the first movie the UK
driver is named chapman which could be a
nod to joey chapman the name of the
third guy to be the marble hero Union
Jack Vega walks on the track and in the
crown of the background one of the
extras is a friend of mine Alex world
you're an easter egg Alex they go
attacks and happy a pepper arrived with
the mark-5 suitcase which they nicknamed
the football which is a nod to the
suitcase with the nuclear codes if I was
the president each new version of Tony's
armor is designed to fix a previous flaw
so the portable mark 5 suitcase lost
Tony a public quick change making quick
change which is an upgrade from the mark
4 which requires stationary heavy
machinery to take on and off but notice
how the mark 5 armor is vulnerable to
whiplashes electric attacks so
the Newmark six armor he builds fixes
that flaw so that when Thor ease of
Mjolnir on Tony and the Avengers the
electric current supercharges a suit
turn in a flaw into an asset Tony's
readings clock vanko's arc reactor at an
output of 1 point 8 2 Giga joules per
second which he criticized as
inefficient because remember the first
arc reactor he made the cable box crafts
had an output a 5 Giga joules per second
and the two foes meet him alive is
because you had a show you took any
messed you know if you could make God
bleed if people were season to believe
it Tony will actually later apply this
lesson against Thanos making that God
bleed to show that he could be killed
hammer breaks Vanko out of prison and
brings them to his hangar and now these
polished white services that this is the
actual interior of Elon Musk's SpaceX
facility for the news photo of Bakos
arrest they actually used a real-life
photo of Mickey Rourke and arrested on
drug charges and he's younger now the
Palladium poisoning continues to eat
away at Tony because he has not yet
truly decoded his father's legacy later
Nick Fury will call it the riddle of his
hearts a riddle that Rhodey alludes to
here and how about the high-tech
crossword puzzle on your neck Hammer
shows Benko his fleet of Iron Man
knock-offs voice too long so hey wish it
had the Russian that Vanko speaks here
translates to you'll talk too much at
tony's party NAT covers his bruises with
makeup a skill that she must know very
well as a black widow super spy you must
hide wounds so that she can hide in
plain sight
and Tony spins records with DJ am Adam
Goldstein who sadly passed away before
this movie came out in the credits you
can see that the film was dedicated to
him and Tony relieves himself in this
suit I know it still traces he's gonna
need to drink down his armors Pete a
water filter might explain how he a
nebula were able to last so long on the
Bennet are an end game Rhodey plays
adult by switching out of his grey suit
for another one the mark 2 armor they
fight and Tony drops in Brody's war
machine moniker you took your shot
Rhodey takes this armor to Edwards Air
Force Base where he's greeted by major
Allen who returns after his amazingly
deliver line in the first film that
thing just took out an f-22 inside a
legal no-fly zone whiplash 2
clear shot take the man does not have
time to redirect his focus now let's
move onto a big don't actually fury find
Stoney at Randy's donuts on a sidewalk
behind Fury is 3:16 for the famous Bible
passage John 3:16 for God so loved the
world that He gave His one and only Son
that whoever believes in Him shall not
perish but have eternal life
though Jackson is known for other Bible
verses this reflects the deeper theme
that fury brings back into this film
Tony as a son who must understand how
much his father loved him so that he can
save the world
nataly's revealed of course as Natasha
Romanov Black Widow in fury mentions
another avenger region to deal with this
Southwest problem is also hinted at by
Colson heading the New Mexico and the
Southwest marker on the map all setting
up the reveal of Thor's hammer mill near
in the post-credits scene Justin Hammer
realizes that Vanko isn't making suits
he's making drones a little better why
drawing better why strong better why is
drone better people make problem me
this is another strategy that Tony will
rip off with his iron Legion drone fleet
though ultimately those drones will
backfire on Tony thanks to Ultron
leading to Tony's key listen to Peter
Parker that it's not about the tech it's
about the person inside if you're
nothing without this shoe then you
should matter ok fury brings up Tony's
father giving him a crate of Howard's
old stuff and while Tony struggles to
reconnect with his dad notice that
whether or not Tony realizes it here he
is wearing this robe this same robe used
to belong to Howard Howard Stark wears
it in the agent Carter one-shot
essentially what shield is doing here is
sealing up Tony in his workshop his
mancave with a box of scraps so that
Tony can once again engineer himself a
new heart cure his ills and transform
once more
hammer equips Rhodey with some heavy
weaponry for his war machine armor
including the ex-wife he's smarter to
write a book book that would make
Ulysses look lame was written in crayon
Ulysses actually was written in crayon
on huge sheets of paper since author
James Joyce was losing this vision
Tony's box of scraps contains a few
Easter eggs a comic book with Captain
America number one the one where he
pledges Hitler on the cover which we
will soon see in the MCU there's also a
map of Antarctica which I've always
wondered could be a nod to Namor with
the original Atlantean Empire located
off the end Rd coast and Howard's
journal is a drawing of the tesseract
and the crate is stamped with project
Pegasus
shield operation that studied the
tesseract from the time Howard will
cover it in the first cat movie through
Wendy Lawson's worked with it and
Captain Marvel through the Avengers and
Tony discovers his father's secret
message I'm limited by the technology of
my time what is and always will be my
greatest creation
[Music]
is you perhaps inspiring Tony to record
a post-mortem for his kid an in-game
Tony buy strawberries for pepper and
notice how he pays for them with this
watch now this is the same watch that
Obadiah Stane gave to him in the first
movie and in the office the Secretary's
baby Arbogast Tony's a longtime
assistant for the comics and he calls
out Nats deception like you serve
anything real about you do you speak
Latin feel like your suit reruns Beck is
in Latin this phrase is a quote from
will show nao translate into the
appearances of things are deceptive and
of course it applies both to nad but
also to the other deception hiding in
plain sight to Tony in this room
Howard's a city of tomorrow design which
Tony uses to derive his new element the
antidote to his poisoning now the movies
novelization identifies this element as
vibranium but Marvel quickly retconned
this with the first cap film like with
vibranium as a substance Howard Stark
used to build cap shield it wouldn't
have been a new previously unknown
element rather it is believed that
Howard's new element was an attempt to
recreate the power of the Infinity
stones during his whole experimentation
with the tesseract that could be why
Tony's reactor is unaffected by the mine
stone and Loki's scepter in Avengers
Tony builds a forge to fuse this new
element Coulson lifts the knockoff cap
shield that we saw in Tony's workstation
first film and they use it to prop up
the coil as always Tony wrecks his home
but earlier he snatched it out of
drunken recklessness here he snatches it
with a purpose and the new arc reactor
he makes is shaped like a triangle with
Delta being the chemistry symbol for a
reaction or change reflecting Tony's
transformation here a second
at the expo Sam Rockwell maintains its
tradition of busting a move in every
movie and the music is pick up the
pieces by average white band featured in
Jon Favreau's movie swingers
also notice the hammer logo it looks a
lot like the Asgard palace if you think
about it the company's name is hammer
maybe suggesting an inspiration from
Asgardian military might and as Hammer
introduces the drones for each branch of
the military the theme music for each
branch plays
[Music]
[Music]
and broody shows up the upgraded war
machine armor when they go hacks the
suit roadies heads up display words
changed from English to Russian they
ghost roads attack and Natasha unhappy
go to stop them he watches Natasha's
awesome takedowns footage that will
later be observed by taskmaster and
Black Widow and the fight spills over
into the Oracle biodome Tony dodges the
blast and then volleys it calling back
the move from the tank and the cave in
the first film Tony also calls back the
laser slice that he learned from the
laser Forge when it sliced through his
home and when they fight Brody has these
drones oil splattered all over them
their blood so stick rody tries he is
the ex-wife on Banco but the hammer tech
sputters out with a little fart and they
ultimately blast free from Banco by
calling back the hand-to-hand blast that
they used earlier hammer gets arrested
real soon
hammer has yet to return in a film but
he did make a brief cameo in the Marvel
one-shot and the same prison seagate
where the fake Mandarin Trevor Slattery
was being held pepper and Tony make up
on a nearby rooftop in difference so
vice during our discord watch a long
pointed out this rooftop kiss resolves
the way Tony left pepper kissed lists in
the first movie and you can join our
discord watch lungs during this infinity
saga re-watch by becoming a patron of
new rock stars at patreon.com slash new
rock stars so Tony meets Nick Fury and
on the screen is a whi H news footage of
the Hulk that we saw in the Incredible
Hulk movie both movies are set during
the same week very big week now this map
shows shield places of interest that has
been very interesting for the past
decade la for Tony Stark's home New
Mexico formula near New York for Harlem
in the recent Queens incident in the
polar ice perhaps for wear cap went down
and then Norway perhaps for that town
where the tesseract was kept but also
there's an African marker for Wakanda
and there is one more in the South
Atlantic
maybe it's the raft prison that was on
Civil War maybe it's just a mobile
Helicarrier or it could be these still
yet to be revealed kingdom of Atlantis
and Namor there was that line that
acquiesce had an endgame that could have
been another clue net it's a quick under
the ocean we handle it by not handling
it Tony's final scene shows how he
applies his father's lesson of legacy
not going alone but being part of a team
it's a great callback
he should be giving me a medal an award
for finally solving the crossword riddle
of
heart teamwork the post-credits scene of
course follows Colson out to New Mexico
where mill near landed with a promising
Thor esketh under cloud
where does Iron Man to rank for you in
the MCU comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Instagram and
Twitter ITA vas follow new rockstars it
subscribed into rock stars for more of
these infinity saga breakdowns or is
next on the list and that guy echoes
perfectly how I end each of these movies
[Music]